díaz canel mármoles
un día simbólico pero que no cambia el
poder del partido comunista como partido
único de cuba' los castros le dan paso a
una generación más joven designada por
ellos mismos por lo que no
necesariamente es más flexible raúl
castro- de 89 años se retiró para ceder
su cargo de primer secretario del
partido comunista cubano al presidente
de la nación miguel díaz canel gracias
por el ejemplo el empuje la fuerza y la
confianza gracias por estar y ayudarnos
a creer en nosotros mismos fue
importante muy importante su apoyo de
aliento durante estos años de
aprendizaje y formación que nos permiten
asumir las responsabilidades en las que
usted y fidel hicieron victoria el
secretariado del partido comunista
cubano cambió por completo su
composición y el nuevo órgano será
integrado por 14 personas 3 menos que el
anterior en las calles mientras unos
celebran el nuevo nombramiento otros
creen que todo seguirá igual
vivimos mucho por la extracción que hizo
que hizo raúl mantiene te deje o
directamente
primer set el partido y presidente
república la unión
para mí
el traspaso de poder llega en un momento
crítico para cuba sumida en su peor
crisis económica de 30 años bajo el
efecto de la pandemia de kobe 19 y el
fortalecimiento del embargo
estadounidense impuesto desde 1962
muchos cubanos están cansados de la
escasez las largas esperas para obtener
productos importados en un 80% y a
través de las redes sociales los más
jóvenes expresan cada vez más sus
frustraciones con el gobierno comunista